FIRST, TRUMP'S EXCESSES IN BLACK
AND WHITE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
THIS IS A SCENE YOU LIKELY DID
NOT SEE ON ONE OF YOUR LOCAL OR
NATIONAL NEWSCASTS.
THE WHITE HOUSE ANNOUNCING A
BOLD PLAN TO CHANGE THE LIVES IN
AMERICA OF SOME OF OUR POOREST
CITIZENS.
THOSE WHO LIVE IN THE MOST
DISTRESSED AND SOMETIMES THE
MOST DANGEROUS NEIGHBORHOODS.
FLANKED BY SENATOR TIM SCOTT AND
BET FOUNDER BOB JOHNSON WITH
VAN JONES LOOKING ON, YOU SEE
THEM THERE, THE PRESIDENT SIGNED
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER CREATING
SOMETHING CALLED THE OPPORTUNITY
AND REVITALIZATION COUNCIL.
IF YOU THINK THIS IS JUST KIND
OF ANOTHER BRICK IN THE
BUREAUCRACY HERE IN D.C.,
SIGNIFYING NOTHING, THINK AGAIN.
LED BY HUD SECRETARY BEN CARSON,
HE WILL COORDINATE EFFORTS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO DELIVER JOBS,
INVESTMENT, AND GROWTH IN
UNDERPRIVILEGED AREAS.
BY THE WAY, IT INCLUDES RURAL
AREAS TOO.
THIS MEANS MORE PRIVATE-SECTOR
MONEY WILL FLOW INTO SOME OF
THESE HIGH-RISK AREAS OR LOW
DEVELOPMENT AREAS.
WHAT WILL THAT DO?
IN TURN, THAT WILL DELIVER JOBS.
>> ISN'T IT A GREAT THING?
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, MR. PRESIDENT,
YOUR REACTION TO MICHAEL COHEN.
>> Laura: OF COURSE YOU HEARD
THAT, THERE ARE FEWER BORDERS ON
HAND.
THEY WEREN'T INTERESTED IN THE
SUBSTANCE OF THE UNDERTAKING.
WHILE THEY WERE INTERESTED IN A
SHOUTING QUESTIONS OUT ABOUT
COHEN.
UNLIKE MOST WHITE HOUSE EVENTS,
STARRING TRUMP, IT WAS NOT
BROADCAST ON CABLE OR C-SPAN OR
ANY OF THE NETWORKS.
I WONDER WHY.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE TRUMP IS DELIVERING
RESULTS.
THOSE THAT THE DEMOCRATS THAT
THEY HAD CO-OPTED POLITICALLY.
IT SMASHES THE PRESSES
RELENTLESS DRUMBEATS ABOUT HOW
THE PRESIDENT JUST DOESN'T LIKE
BLACK PEOPLE.
>> WHAT MORE DO WE NEED TO SIRI
OR HEAR FROM THIS RACIST MAN?
>> HERE WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
HAS ONCE AGAIN SAID RACIST AND
DESPICABLE WORDS ABOUT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
>> THE POLICY HAS BEEN
ANTI-PEOPLE OF COLOR.
CONTINUES POLICIES THAT I
BELIEVE ARE RACIST IN NATURE.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THESE
UNITED STATES IS RACIST.
>> THE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO HARBOR
RACIST FEELINGS ABOUT PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
>> Laura: IT'S JUST
DESPICABLE.
EVERY TIME I WATCH THOSE, I AM
LIKE, I DON'T WANT TO PLAY THEM
ANYMORE.
MEDIA MOGUL BOB JOHNSON, ONE OF
THE MOST PROMINENT AND
SUCCESSFUL AFRICAN-AMERICANS
PROBABLY ON THE PLANET,
OBVIOUSLY BEGGED TO DISAGREE
WITH THE MONTAGE.
HE WAS ON HAND TO RECOGNIZE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DRIVE AND
COMMITMENT TO HELP LOW INCOME
AMERICANS.
>> JUST RECENTLY, YOUR
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR SIGNED A
HISTORIC DOCUMENT THAT CREATED
SOMETHING CALLED AUTO
PORTABILITY.
IT'S DESIGNED TO REDUCE
RETIREMENT LEAKAGE AMONG LOW
INCOME 401(K) ACCOUNT HOLDERS
WHO TEND TO CASH OUT.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU SHOULD KNOW
THIS, 60% OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN
AND HISPANIC AMERICANS CASH OUT
OF THEIR 401(K) ACCOUNTS.
THIS PROGRAM WILL PUT CLOSE TO
$800 BILLION BACK IN THE
RETIREMENT POCKET OF MINORITY
AMERICANS.
SO I JUST WANT TO APPLAUD YOU
FOR THAT.
>> Laura: NO COVERAGE.
I HAD TO PLAY THAT JUST BECAUSE
NO ONE SAW IT.
NOW, YOU SEE, THERE ARE A LOT OF
POLITICIANS OUT THERE WHO
TRAFFIC IN BROMIDES SHINING WITH
A VENEER OF REAL COMPASSION.
>> HOPE IS THE INSISTENCE THAT
NO MATTER HOW TOUGH OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES, THERE ARE BETTER
DAYS AHEAD.
IF WE PERSIST, DESPITE ALL OF
OUR INDIVIDUAL FAILINGS AND ALL
OF OUR INADEQUACIES, TOGETHER WE
CAN OVERCOME.
>> Laura: THAT'S NICE.
I GUESS THAT HIS NOBEL PRIZE
MATERIAL.
THE PROBLEM IS TALKING ABOUT
HOPE IS BEAUTIFUL BUT IT WON'T
BRING BUSINESS INTO YOUR
COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE WHO CAN GET JOBS TEND TO
HAVE MORE HOPE.
DESPAIR AND DESPAIR AND CRIME IN
PLACES LIKE CHICAGO AND
BALTIMORE SPIRALED OUT OF
CONTROL DURING MUCH OF OBAMA'S
EIGHT YEARS.
BUT I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
SAY.
BUT LAURA, OBAMA AND THE
DEMOCRATS CARE MORE THAN
DONALD TRUMP.
LOOK, YOU CAN SEE IT.
YOU CAN FEEL IT.
THEY CARE.
THEN THEY WILL BRING UP
CHARLOTTESVILLE AND THE S-HOLE
COMMENT TRUMP MADE TO DRIVE
THEIR POINTS HOME.
EVEN FOR THE SAKE OF ARGUMENT I
CAN SEE THOSE POINTS, THE
TONALITY, THE WORDING, MAYBE
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT THAT WAY,
FINE.
I ASKED THE FOLLOWING.
WHO CARES MORE ABOUT AMERICA IN
PARTICULAR THE WORKING POOR?
THE GUY WHO DELIVERS RESULTS,
RECORD LOW ON EMPLOYMENT,
OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND A CHANCE
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
OR A PARTY THAT IS ALL TALK AND
NO ACTION?
I WILL TAKE THE FORM OR ANY DAY.
OH, AND BY THE WAY, THE PRESS
DID FIND ONE ANGLE ON THE
OPPORTUNITY ZONE.
THEY THOUGHT PART OF THE STORY
WAS WORTH COVERING.
JARED AND TRUMP HIMSELF ARE ONLY
PUSHING THESE INNER-CITY
INVESTMENT INCENTIVES BECAUSE
THEY WILL MAKE MONEY OFF THEIR
OWN REAL ESTATE HOLDINGS.
PLEASE.
SECRETARY BEN CARSON CAME ON MY
RADIO SHOW YESTERDAY, AND HE
SWATTED THIS WHOLE THING AWAY.
>> THESE ZONES WERE PICKED BY BY
THE GOVERNORS.
THEY WERE NOT PICKED BY JARED
KUSHNER.
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF PEOPLE IN
THE COUNTRY WHO ALREADY HAVE
REAL ESTATE IN THOSE ZONES.
WILL THEY BENEFIT?
PROBABLY.
WHY SHOULDN'T THEY BENEFIT?
WHY SHOULDN'T EVERYBODY BENEFIT?
WHY SHOULDN'T WE CREATE WIN-WIN
SITUATIONS?
>> Laura: I WANT TO SEE MORE
OF BEN CARSON OUT THERE, BY THE
WAY.
I LOVED WHAT HE HAD TO SAY.
ONCE AGAIN, THE MEDIA PROVES
ITSELF TO BE ABSOLUTELY
INCAPABLE OF COVERING VIRTUALLY
ANYTHING ABOUT THE WORK THE
PRESIDENT DOES TO TRY TO RESTORE
OUR COUNTRY.
NOT EVEN AN INKLING OF
OBJECTIVITY.
HE DIDN'T DO THIS, BY THE WAY,
TO BENEFIT A FEW OF HIS PALS ARE
THE PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR HIM BUT
HE IS DOING THIS TO TRY TO
BENEFIT THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
SERVED SO POORLY BY POLITICIANS
OF BOTH PARTIES FOR DECADES.
BUT I'M TELLING YOU DESPITE
EVERYTHING THAT IS SWIRLING
AROUND HIM, THE DEMOCRATS
OBSESSION WITH IMPEACHMENT, THE
INDICTMENTS, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA, THE PRESIDENT
CONTINUES TO DO WORK THAT OTHER